climate change is creating new
challenges for the global wine industry
this morning in our eye on Earth series
we're gonna explore how the changing
environment is actually affecting the
production of the popular sparkling wine
Prosecco Seth Doane meant to went to man
sway it's about 30 miles outside of
Venice Italy to see just how they are
working to make sure that warmer
temperatures do not end up altering the
wines taste and pungency climate change
is threatening centuries of Italian
tradition in this region famed for
Prosecco Paolo Tomasello says extreme
weather is posing new challenges at his
vineyard - nuta Tomasulo
climate change is a big problem when
it's very hot when it's raining it's
raining very much
Prosecco he explained should have low
alcohol and high acidity but high
temperatures and earlier ripening
produce the opposite effect
it's our Prosecco the result of our
reports so Thomas chela is testing new
techniques and letting Italian
government scientist Diego Tomasi used
the vineyard as a sort of laboratory the
climate change is making affect on the
acidity because more temperature means
are also low acidity Tomasi showed us
grapes that have burned on the vine
winemakers are sometimes forced to
harvest weeks earlier in the hottest
months which can produce different
aromas and flavors the vine is like a
thermometer is very sensitive to
temperature at Italy's creo Research
Center they're hearing from winemakers
who were planting at higher elevations
and have discovered the timing between
growing stages is now shorter why do you
blame climate change because of course
the soil is more or less the same the
variety more or less is the same and so
everything that we are discovering now
depend of the climate which a tenuta
Thomas chela means making some
adjustments like cutting back foliage to
stop photosynthesis a way to reduce the
amount of alcohol that comes from the
grapes and piping nitrogen into the
water to boost acidity
growers could plant new vines better
suited to changing climactic conditions
but new vines take years to produce and
ultimately change the character of a
wine and a place as climate change
creeps into yet another aspect of life
for CBS this morning Seth Doane men's
way Italy so much work I know I didn't
know Prosecco had such a high acidic
content yeah another and the impacts of
climate change just keep bearing out